hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the very last episode of
the great work no matter how long it
takes I'm going to get this all done in
one I want to finish this up in 20 parts
20 parts is a long series for a custom
story ok the college must not be allowed
to revive more Iain I didn't know that
was their objective but ok the cultists
have an orb and I'm in the sewers so I
need to find a way to wait a minute hey
what do you know this is the same place
my back at the whatchamacallit in London
or whatever I think this might be the
library err or not the library well that
means that this is open still this is
still here the great underneath this
probably might be Elida might not have
the key
oh it's blocked up ok so that's
definitely a no-go yeah I'm back in the
old place where I was nothing useful
here don't see why anything would be
alright let's see I actually thought I
climbed up to get here so I'm not sure
how I'm in the sewers or if the facility
they have is just way underground that's
probably it
ok so everything seems to be similarly
blocked up as before
oh hello this is broken open now I am
supposed to go this way
okay hi all right then I think they
sealed off all the other exits and I
have no doubt that a water monster is
gonna pop out at any moment
nibble my giblets it's locked
good thing I have this hammer and
chipper good thing I have this key four
padlocks haha is that just a generic
padlock key universally works with every
single padlock in existence oh well this
looks simple loud splash I got my volume
turned up again
alright let's say aye aye aye aye aye
aye aye aye her dead no the other way oh
lordy Lou okay come on now crank it
crank it oh yeah crank it okay now I
need to release it somehow I rapidly
going the other way
hang on come here oh you shut up a [ __ ]
oh my god
okay now you're stuck I gotta somehow
cut the line with this padlock okay
either way I need to make that drop so
to do that I'll go through here it's
locked
good thing I got this key four padlocks
hey I'm Way too smart for this game
I'm not way too smart for this okay
we're going this way now I always wanted
to check out what was on the other side
of this river and never see what's on
there oh look at this this looks
interesting
let's not visit that other part anytime
soon oh this looks like a good run let's
just jump in the corner here hang on I
can move this No
all right there's nothing there it's
like a Bible and box jars nothing useful
this is just a death trap room there's
nothing in here for me if it could block
up the door with this just try getting
in here now dick we can do what are you
gonna do [ __ ]
is there something under there I can't
move this out of the way so there's no
point anyway okay there's nothing in
here that's the first time I've ever
seen you know ever since the original
amnesia oh he's a common I've seen in
the in the in the demo real they
actually used a table to block up the
door I've never seen a room that let you
do that and ha ha ha
I did it the right way you're oh okay
never mind then I thought I was onto
something special there but I cut off
[ __ ] I just got trapped in this corner
how are you son of a [ __ ] okay that
table did nothing and I'm gonna go back
now so screw you a-hole
screw you and oh yeah
how did he get so got my night bra take
a pair on the finger my wrath
come everybody [ __ ] out no nothing in
here
there's no point why am I here I need to
get them to cut the line no no no no no
no no no I should have put the padlock
back on I'll can't get through there
Kenya dick ah oh you can that's hardly
what I would call fair lookie here cut
this line for me do it for me do for
your uncle Baba oh well what the hell
how stupid he's an a-hole obviously oh
it's just ridiculousness
oh I'm all the way back in the beginning
us bowl a bowl I don't think the maker
of this game intended for the players to
die as much as what why have me
specifically every normal average player
would not die as this much a normal
average player would have replaced this
heavy padlock on the door before running
away like a giant baby and then he
wouldn't have been able to knock down
the door but I'm not a normal player I
am markiplier and I still need to figure
out how to drop this on that okay let's
take a closer look at this room to see
what was really in here while not
looking at it in a blind panic ah see
there was a saw in here that I didn't
notice because there was too much blood
in my eyeballs and those are monster
shoving his claw up my anus
alright so saw let's solve this problem
let's solve this uh I saw you I need to
I saw the solution I can't all is gonna
be like that one episode where I
couldn't find where I need to click this
object to I know that a
that peg a goes into socket B how do I
get you to go into yo oh my god
Jesus Oh [ __ ] hell ah ah ah my god
dammit
oh [ __ ] hell why Oh piss on a brick
okay guys I have my game actually
crashed in the male lab that's why I got
a monster so haunting me but I managed
to get away from him
there was this little rope sitting here
and apparently that I need to climb up
here to make this fall down that is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard in my
life
can I use this item in this way well why
the [ __ ] not
oh why couldn't I
why couldn't I have cut it from there
why you make me run around GameMaker
dick punching party back it on and this
is the last episode so I can't change my
mind again everybody get out your boxing
gloves and brass knuckles and nylon rope
so we can tie this ah god damn I mean
like bah it's like just ba wanna kill up
baby yak each Tommy split his mind and
put invisible grew weaker what is he
freaking to Voldemort here but pieces of
his soul in a shard guys I remember this
is where that thing and the thing in the
thing went and the guy moves man behind
me suddenly popped up out of nowhere
it's awfully darker in here okay let's
calm down we got a crisis to solve here
gotta stop more Iain yah yah yah de yada
let's see how Samuels doing
I bet he's dead I hope he's dead cuz I
still know aha it's this guy again
what an unfortunate way to die all right
let's go see think Samuels back this way
maybe I don't know
uh yeah yeah right here
Sabra do youdo is that you again
no what is it you want this time hi it's
me Samuel it's me
I cannot use this key uh huh why can't I
talk to him
Samuel I'm trying to [ __ ] you then I
don't care
Samuel you can go die oh let me me me
there
maybe the hammer and chipper there we go
guarded by a horrible shadow if you
misuse it you'll bring it around down
upon all of us we will meet the same
fate as your haunted
uh-huh hi I'm here to you know save you
can I do anything
please remember I'll hack you to pieces
okay maybe Samuel is a good guy all
right never go never mind I can't do
anything for him why don't I say words
why am I such a silent protagonist in
this okay whatever carrying on moving
forward
Samuel is slipped into madness die I'm
here to conquer the world Oh
visit back into the blue area the man
twisted and strained against his bonds
as maureen readied the scalpel in one
hand and held the freshly acquired shard
in the other the pain would not last for
long he assured the prisoner soon his
mind would not be capable of recognizing
pain ah oh it's dark in here
I remember this door well whatever okay
is there anything that's left here for
me aha a chemistry pot go get a dark box
closet ha ha get matter no time for
we're out I did not have a lot of time
there this dick of a closet was not
playing games
I just picked up some freakin saltpeter
what's a big deal I can't open the door
anymore not fair brick god damn not fair
that is full tank top man that was just
intended to just kill you without any
chance of survival
all the lights are round why are all the
lights out anyway whatever I'm
collecting ingredients for something
explosive I'm guessing I'm on a run out
of oil in about two seconds here I think
I know where I need to go but I'm just
double-checking this area here all the
lights are out every single candle in
here
okay I don't think I'm supposed to go
this way yep let's go wait hang on maybe
I am I don't want to leave anything to
chance here all right god it's dark okay
is anything anything anything anything
anything anything anything anything nope
uh-uh
okay let's just get out of here what's
over here locked okay I think I know
where of god piss it's dark I know where
I need to go which is the UM on the
opposite side of the elevator there was
a door that had question marks on it I
think I need to go in there man a dark
dark there was also a room to the left
here that was ska huh that's a wall
those locked the store was bashed open
anything in here please tell me there's
something in here tinderbox useful stuff
no room closet with nothing nothing
nothing nothing another oh that's a door
god I can't see anything and I'm about
to run out of oil here okay
closet nothing nothing waste of time
waste of oil waste of resources waste of
my life bloody hell that rumbling I
think that dark oh hello
do cots do I need to melt that down
again I remember in the beginning I
melted that down into something special
so hopefully that means I needed I get
to do something soon ok nothing nothing
nothing nothing log down to Darren um
yes ok this way to the elevator was
there oil in here just oh yeah just as I
run out yes still Yoel does not last
long enough anything else that I might
need nothing ok let's go let's go
quickly before I run out of oil again
yes here right here mister I am Dori
having lost contact with the partners 10
years ago was surprised to see Maureen
on his route doorstep ragged and weary
it began to offered the hand help but
Yohan stopped him with a raised hand
samuel has been keeping secrets from you
all no not Samuel I knew he was a dick I
still sense that his imprisonment is our
elaborate ruse hmm
that's a cultist please don't bother me
I'm just trying to get on my merry way
to go destroy all of your hopes and
dreams that's all I want to do oh it's a
big circle wait a minute oh hi what does
that boat to be more Iain nice don't
seem right we throw a rock at him or
some hi Bonnie
I was going there friend hell what's
this well this looks warm and inviting
ones it gonna turn diabolical
what do we got here something special
lots of books doesn't seem like anything
important nothing I can click on nice
you lights okay elevator okay down we go
into the darkness and the depths of hell
why not charge forward road to 300
through shot and shell blah blah I don't
know I like the music like the music
again it's been a while since I comment
and then that but pretty much throughout
the whole thing the music spent very
very original there some secret hitting
in amongst all these boxes I would think
so
all these boxes need to get the [ __ ]
out of here so that I can find your
secrets and plumb your depths oh yeah
let's see here
nope nope nope no no no no no no no no
nothing just a whole bunch of boxes in a
possible hiding spot okay I'm coming up
on that looks like a whole lot of some
what can I do about the pillar looks
cracked in week haha do I need to throw
stuff at it till it breaks
I am totally for that maybe I gotta
build a giant pillar ah [ __ ] you door
and climb up there oh no wait da
I have saltpeter I need explosives I
need to find a chemistry set which was
probably where that um where the monster
was the cultists I just need to get away
from him I go up thank you I have I have
do cots and saltpeter and if I can find
another ingredient I can explosives to
bring more he ain't down to my level
which is not a good level to be on no
one wants to be on my level
all right taste your defeat more vein
you have met your intellectual equal
I am so skilled as a combatant that you
will find your death will not be swift
you and I have reached the climax of the
epitome of evil with which you have been
wrought find now these last days that
you live in agony for I will have no
mercy upon your soul aha
there we are potage what is this oil of
vitriol perfect wait I still don't have
an actual chemistry set here dammit I
didn't see another chemistry set
anywhere else but I got all the
necessary ingredients ah got something
there mixtures of all swords ah man I
need something else hang on I need this
potage here huh
no man can get a piece of it
nah damn it I'm missing something
aha there was a reason why I still had
that auric hydroxide oh no way that's
awesome why can I pick that up right
then I need to take this with me
somewhere ah it doesn't that's weird it
doesn't turn when I move okay so I got
this I don't know what I need to do with
this though maybe I could just throw
this at the guy maybe I don't know I
don't know what I'm doing I'm just a
dumbass trying to do chemistry and it's
really dark don't ask I don't know where
I'm going
nobody knows but I got that and it's
glowing now so that's that's good that's
good maybe I need to go back I don't
know I don't know what I'm doing but I
got a glowing thing here I don't know
huh all right here we go buddy you think
you can mess with me
ha ha it worked
Howard
yeah suck on that more Iain hope you had
fun dying in a pit mine the orb is mine
the orb is now mine forever shall III
alright I'm not that's the stupidest
voice I've ever done in this in all of
my videos that's probably the stupidest
voice ever okay so now that I have it
what am I supposed to do with it an
ancient and powerful artifact got a guy
that I think I'm supposed to go for an
annoying nerd but that's what I already
a.m. oh ah ah no no you're not gonna
take my orb you [ __ ]
[ __ ] off [ __ ] you ah let me dick suck it
down you can't stop me you can't stop me
nobody can stop me I am too ah as they
watched the wilted Rose spring back to
life
yeah go get me [ __ ] I'm going into the
okay that's locked that was a bad
decision
oh don't know where I'm going where am I
going
we're a gang I don't know do I go back
to the prison ah I guess maybe I can get
out of here the same way I came in but
now I fell through what am I supposed to
do
what am i doing what am i doing what am
i doing I'm I have no idea where I'm
going
maybe I wasn't supposed to go this way I
don't know ah yes I'm out of oil ah shat
where am I going I'm going back to
Samuel because that's the only thing I
know what to do that's the only guy here
quite literally this he's the only guy
here Samuel Samuel I need your help
buddy yeah I don't want to
whoa what the what are you doing there
Samuel
all right then what is going on here see
okay
okay bye Samuel
I guess
I know that there are multiple endings
I'm wondering if I just found one of
them
it looks almost nice bottle of booze and
ice nope actually this is the place
where I was before this is huh this is
Morey Ames mansion isn't it bottle of
Damascus rose potion isn't that what
makes you lose your mind the shadow will
destroy everything connected to the orb
invisible College that temple and myself
it will not however destroy the scars
these events have dealt you these
memories would surely haunt you for the
rest of your natural-born life ah you
deserve better than thus I leave you a
potion made from Damascus rose a single
drink of this liquid and you will forget
everything that happens since you're
right
we'll have the chance to live a normal
life there'll be no one left to
remembers the or banal events that
transpired with it ah goodbye Jules it
was a pleasure to work with you I pray
that you have a rich fulfilling life
Samuel or maybe Samuel was good after
all and maybe he's a double-crossing
douchebag yeah that's gotta be it he's
trying to trick me somehow take your for
himself
I refuse to believe it he refused I will
not take your stupid potion I will not
aren't you bro for you yeah okay maybe
that's the only option here I still
don't see the eyes in this forest that
you guys were talking about okay
whatever here we go bring it down no not
the acid don't drink the acid Frank
don't drink the coins there's nothing
else I can do here we go oh that's it
that is the end holy crap man that was a
great custom story and that was just one
of the endings I know that there are
multiple ones and someone said that a
while ago I picked one path that it
could have branched into a couple paths
but still Damascus that's the guy
Damascus came an awliya everyone who
worked on this is awesome we're gonna
the dick punching party's still on but
it's gonna be done with love
all right cats all that dick punching
party some people actually thought I was
seriously angry at the developers and I
wasn't I was just joking around
Python blue did a great job with the
music at that like a website or
something or coming here I don't know I
can't understand what they're saying
there but either way that was an
incredible incredible incredibly made
ads amnesia custom story it really can
show what happens when talented people
put serious effort into a game and it
deserves every no excuse me it deserves
everything that came to it was an
absolutely amazing amnesia custom story
everyone should try for themselves
because there are multiple endings and
you can get a different things try to
make different choices than what I made
absolutely terrifying well done with new
monsters and all that they were actually
well professionally animated and look
like it I like all the music in this one
I'm gonna look up Python rows or
something like that oh see yeah
those are all the songs that were used
either way all awesome man great great
great great great great great great
great break break can't say enough about
it I'm actually gonna try to go through
all these because I mean all of it all
of it was just an amazing custom sorry I
mean some of the puzzles were a little
wonky some of the choices that they made
were a little questionable they could
have been done of done better but I mean
with a more professional studio Quality
Assurance testing might have been
allowable to work out the kinks um one
who did this on their own ten ah ten
five stars to thumbs-up beyond great es
5 T six that's a different one well
that's different and that's not part
that might be a different code to
something else I either way is t5 I'm
not going to remember that so if you
guys want to try for yourself maybe that
was a code to the end for sticking with
me for this playthrough see if there's
something special in like the the
installation folder is either way thank
you so much Damascus and thank you
everybody somewhat for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
hello
well